avevo 67 anni e le maestre le mamme
dicevano che il camorrista
io ero un bambino buono e bravo e anche
timido e non sapevo quello che voi
sapete che si nasce in un certo
quartiere si appartiene a una certa
famiglia e la vita tua e segnata così ha
scritto uno dei miei ragazzi in uno dei
nostri libri la differenza delle altre
carceri minorili italiane dove la
presenza e soprattutto di stranieri
i ragazzi di nisida sono di napoli e
dell'hinterland
a conferma che nel nostro territorio
permangono problematiche economiche
sociali e culturali cui non si presta un
efficace attenzione le ragazze sono
invece provengono dal sud italia e anche
dal resto del paese perché in easy
dell'unico carcere femminile minorile
del sud fino a qualche anno fa erano
quasi tutte rom
adesso sono in prevalenza italiane
i ragazzi e le ragazze che arrivano a
nisida non sono in media scolarizzati
ma anche quando lo so lo sono non hanno
né interesse né competenze nei confronti
della lettura e della scrittura
il nostro obiettivo quindi è far loro
sperimentare per parafrasare cha cha che
l'italiano non è l'italiano e il
ragionare e quindi è la possibilità di
decidere con la propria testa senza
farsi influenzare e determinare da
problematiche familiari o ambientali ed
è anche la capacità di far saltare il
vincolo più grosso che li condiziona
ovvero la con la convinzione che il loro
futuro sia determinato dal loro passato
che il loro sia un destino già
irrevocabilmente scritto negli anni
abbiamo adottato vari percorsi di
scrittura un giornalino che tuttora
facciamo i testi elaborati attraverso
altri testi poesie
e testi teatrali e fotoromanzi se cambia
il finale è il titolo di uno dei nostri
fotoromanzi a indicare come qualsiasi
sia il nostro percorso
l'obiettivo è certo quello di accrescere
le competenze linguistiche ma è
soprattutto quello di dare ai ragazzi
strumenti per agire sulla crescita del
se negli ultimi anni abbiamo adottato
una modalità di scrittura che definiamo
mediata inclusiva e collettiva che ha
raggiunto buoni obiettivi
lo abbiamo fatto all'interno di un
progetto generale nisida come parco
letterario è naturale che ha visto in
questi anni sull'isola la riapertura
degli antichi sentieri borbonici verso
porto paone arricchiti da steli e
panchine letterarie che sono prodotti
nei nostri laboratori di ceramica e di
edilizia
per quanto riguarda più strettamente la
scrittura una trentina di autori
napoletani hanno lavorato in classe con
noi del tutto gratuitamente producendo
otto volumi di racconti i premi tre
volumi riguardano soprattutto l'isola e
la sua storia e la sua storia letteraria
i successivi quattro invece hanno
consentito ai ragazzi di parlare di loro
stessi attraverso lo schermo della
grammatica della sintassi delle attese
del futuro e dell'immaginario l'ultimo
volume che è stato pubblicato a cavallo
tra il settantesimo anniversario della
proclamazione della repubblica il
settantesimo anniversario dell'entrata
in vigore della costituzione riguarda il
rapporto tra i ragazzi e le leggi
fondamentali dello stato tutti questi
libri presentano tre parti
i racconti degli autori una carrellata
di iscritti dei ragazzi e il backstage
di tutto il percorso
ogni anno quindi io scelgo un tema e ci
lavoro con i ragazzi sia prima che dopo
l'incontro che i ragazzi stessi anno con
gli scrittori ogni scrittore lavora con
ragazzi sulla base delle proprie idee di
scrittura del genere letterario che
preferisce delle proprie suggestioni si
fa aiutare talvolta dai libri da
spezzoni di film da fotografie spesso
usa semplicemente le proprie parole
poi sulla base di quello che i ragazzi
scrivono del dibattito del che
interviene in quelle ore delle emozioni
che si avvertono in quei momenti
l'autore scrive il suo racconto e lo
riporta in classe e ragazzi dopo il
dibattito con i ragazzi
il racconto viene pubblicato insieme
agli altri nella raccolta dell'anno con
questa modalità
noi abbiamo ottenuto tre obiettivi
fondamentali i ragazzi diventano tutti i
protagonisti del racconto si sa chi ha
un minimo di capacità di scrittura
chi riesce a elaborare un po di tempo di
trama che riesce a delineare un
personaggio ma anche chi non ne ha
nessuna di competenze ed è in grado di
indicare per esempio soltanto un
aggettivo interessante tutti quanti
diventano con scrittori del racconto
i ragazzi sono molto soddisfatti del
fatto che l'autore prenda un pezzo del
loro scritto per usarlo e quando
l'autore viene per la prima volta a
leggere il proprio racconto in classe
loro controllano sul loro foglio
qual è la parola qual è il termine qual
è la frase che l'autore ha utilizzato
nel racconto d'autore i ragazzi si
riconoscono rivedono le proprie emozioni
propri sentimenti e le proprie emozioni
ma lì me li vedono attraverso una
distanza propria della narrativa quindi
con questa modalità di scrittura che è
tesa più all espressione e alla
comunicazione rispetto alla correttezza
grammaticale e sintattica i ragazzi
possono provare a loro stessi di essere
capaci di qualcosa di positivo anche in
un campo per loro
veramente ostico come l'italiano scritto
e questo processo di auto conoscenza che
chiaramente anche un processo
terapeutico di autoconoscenza viene
rafforzato
all'interno del laboratorio di teatro
quando i nostri racconti vengono ripresi
e riadattati per dei reading che vengono
fatti per scolaresche tra associazioni
per la gente amica di nisida che viene
ad assistere ai nostri spettacoli i
libri che produciamo diventano uno spot
formidabile per il processo di lettura e
scrittura perché i ragazzi sono
abbastanza curiosi di vedere i libri in
cui ci sono c'è traccia di se stessi e
dei loro compagni sono anche i curiosi
di leggere i testi degli autori che
hanno conosciuto in carne e ossa
di conseguenza sia i nostri libri sia i
libri degli autori che lavorano con con
noi
entrano nelle letture normali della
classe e vengono chiesti in prestito noi
abbiamo una biblioteca e il prestito
viene molto favorito i ragazzi che
partecipano al laboratorio di scrittura
hanno piacere a parteciparci anche
l'anno successivo e molti dei ragazzi
che arrivano a nisida chiedono di far
parte di questo laboratorio perché ne
sentono parlare con dei compagni oppure
in qualche modo vengono a contatto con i
nostri libri il laboratorio quindi oltre
ad avere una ricaduta positiva sulla
comunicazione sulla lingua ha un grande
effetto di crescita dell'autostima per i
ragazzi ha anche e diventa un corso di
educazione emozionale e sentimentale
perché i laboratori scritture una delle
pochissime occasioni in cui nel in cui a
nisida ragazzi e ragazze lavorano
insieme e diventa anche un corso di
educazione alla bellezza alla bellezza
della parola del dialogo del confronto
addirittura alla bellezza della natura
perché dalle aule della scuola dove dove
a differenza di tutti gli altri ambienti
del carcere non ci sono sbarre cielo e
mare possono essere goduti liberamente
se il corso di scrittura una ricaduta
positiva sui ragazzi ce l'ha anche sugli
autori che dai ragazzi ricevono
moltissimo ma certamente per gli autori
non sono una platea
facile i nostri ragazzi infatti per e
tuckson adolescenti o giovani adulti ma
per esperienze di vita
sono veramente molto adulti addirittura
vecchi e nello stesso tempo hanno
atteggiamenti infantili tipici di chi
l'infanzia non l'ha mai vissuta
i nostri ragazzi non hanno avuto né modo
né tempo di diventare figli e spesso si
ritrovano ad essere già padri il
laboratorio e cioè i libri voglio dire
sono interessanti per chi legge perché
mettono a contatto con la realtà
effettiva le ragazze in visita che è
molto diversa da quella di propinata dai
mass media
il lettore lo può fare in due modi lo
può fare attraverso la mediazione del
racconto degli autori e quindi con
attraverso la capacità che la
letteratura a di trasformare e storie
individuali in storie universali sia
ascoltando direttamente la voce dei
ragazzi che nella sua frammentarietà
rappresenta però una sorta di
autobiografia collettiva laboratorio
continua anche quest'anno e anzi
quest'anno gode di un finanziamento
grazie all italian teacher price
quest'anno faremo una variazione nella
primavera prossima la primavera il 2018
pubblicheremo il nostro primo romanzo
quindi gli autori che lavorano
quest'anno con noi sono sette hanno
scritto un canovaccio sulla base delle
precedenti esperienze sulla base di
quello che i ragazzi hanno scritto in
questi anni ma adesso in classe stanno
modificando ampliando questo loro
racconto in maniera che poi alla fine il
romanzo sia un lavoro effettivamente
integrato tra i ragazzi e nei ragazzi e
gli autori quello che non è modificato
rispetto al passato e la nostra fiducia
nelle parole soprattutto nelle parole
scritte
perché le parole scritte hanno la
capacità di curare le ferite di
restringere i fantasmi della mente di
incanalare emozioni e soprattutto si
possono declinare al futuro non solo i
verbi tutte le parole si possono
declinare in un futuro che non è già
scritto ma che può essere scritto con
responsabilità e libertà ha scritto uno
dei miei ragazzi
in uno dei nostri libri io l'italiano lo
parlo bene e lo scrivo anche meglio
scelgo con cura le parole e so anche il
loro colore
l'amore è rossa come il fuoco l'odio e
grigia la libertà è come il cielo la
mamma è la mamma e l'arcobaleno
io so la differenza tra dire io ho
sentimenti valori e principi e io sono
un ragazzo di sentimenti valori e
principi penso che non ci sia niente di
più bello che poter esternare tramite
parole i propri stati d'animo e il
proprio modo di essere
grazie
[Applauso]